[موسيقى]
ما اسباب هذه الحمله
اسمحوا لي سيد عبد العظيم من خلالكم ان
احيي عاملي شبكه الجزيره والمشاهدين
الكرام ونحن سعداء جدا لاستضافتكم
في الحقيقه تحولت الهجره في ايامنا هذه
الى مشكله عالميه ومن ذلك ان منظمه الهجره
العالميه التابعه للامم المتحده نشرت
تقريرا في العام 2022
قالت فيه ان عدد اللاجئين في العالم وصل
الى 281 مليونا وهو رقم كبير اليس كذلك
اما نحن في تركيا فنستضيف اربع ملايين
وثمانمائه وثلاثه واربعين الف لاجئ نظامي
منهم مليون
و252 الف مقيم وحاصل على بطاقه اقامه و
292 الف لاجئ مقيم وفقا لقانون الحمايه
الدوليه بالاضافه الى ثلاثه ملايين وثلاثه
وسبعه الاف سوري يقيمون في اطار الحمايه
المؤقته هؤلاء الذين اشرت اليهم يوصفون
لانهم لاجئون نظاميون لكن بالاضافه الى
ذلك هنالك لاجئون غير نظاميين من هم هؤلاء
اللاجئون غير النظاميين يا استاذ عبد
العظيم تعريف اللاجئين غير النظاميين ليس
خاصا بتركيا وحدها وهو تعريف موحد في كل
انحاء العالم
دعني اشرح لك هو تعريف يعتمد على ثلاثه
عناصر وهي طريقه دخولهم البلد واقامتهم
فيه وخروجهم منه واي اجنبي ارتكب امرا غير
قانوني في هذه الشؤون الثلاثه يتم تعريفه
بانه لاجئ غير نظامي هو السؤال سيدي
الوزير لماذا الان هذا اكيد من حق تركيا
ان تخرج اللاجئين غير الشرعيين لا احد
يزاحمها في احد الحق لكن
ربما
ربط هذا بعد الانتخابات هو هذا السبب
في الحقيقه كافه حكومات حزب العداله
والتنميه قبل الانتخابات كافحت اللجوء غير
النظامي والاحصاءات تثبت ذلك
اما فيما يتعلق باللجوء غير النظامي فاننا
نطبق ما تقتضيه القوانين من اجل تحقيق امن
شعبنا ورفاهيته واستقراره وهو ما يتضمن
التدابير ارجاع اللاجئين غير النظاميين
الى بلدانهم
خلال الشهر الاخير اسسنا 20 مركزا مؤقتا
للهجره في اسطنبول وكما تطلب قوى الامن من
مواطنين الاتراك ابرازه هوياتهم وفقا
لقانون الهويه التركي فان قوات الامن تطلب
ممن تشك فيهم من الاجانب ان يبرزوا ما
بحوزتهم من اوراق ثبوتيه واذا لم يكن
الاجنبي يحمله هويه او جواز سفر فاننا
ندعوه لاحد مراكز الهجره المؤقته العشرين
هذه للتثبت من بصمته الكترونيا فان كان قد
دخل البلاد بشكل قانوني فان السجلات تثبت
ذلك فورا ونشكر الشخص ثم نعتذر اليه اما
ان تبين انه غير مسجل لدخوله البلاد
بطريقه غير قانونيه اي انه لاجئ غير نظامي
فعندها تقوم قوات الامن بايصاله لاحد
مراكز الاعاده ليتم بعد ذلك التنسيق مع
قنصليه بل ده ويتم تامين وثائق تمكنه من
السفر ثم تبدا بعد ذلك عمليه الترحيل حسب
الاجراءات القانونيه
سيد الوزير نحن عندنا مسؤوليه الان واحنا
نتحدث معك ان هناك اصوات
تتحدث
بغير هذا بخصوصا من قبل اللاجئين وتحديدا
السوريين كثير من اللاجئين السوريين الذين
تم ترحيلهم الى شمال سوريا يتحدثون عن ان
اوراقهم صحيحه لديهم اقامات لا زالت بعضهم
لا زالت عوائلهم موجوده تم ترحيلهم كيف
نفهم هذا الوضع لهؤلاء السوريين تحديدا
قامت تركيا بثلاث عمليات عسكريه في سوريا
درع الفرات نبع السلام وغصن الزيتون لقد
انشانا منطقه امنه وهادئه بفضل هذه
العمليات واستطعنا من خلالها ان نؤمن
منطقه امنه وهادئه لسته ملايين سوري كانوا
سيتوجهون نحو تركيا لولا هذه المنطقه لم
تكتفي تركيا بانشاء منطقه امنه فقط بل
تقوم مع الاطراف المتبرعه الاخرى باحياء
المنطقه من خلال فعاليات تعليميه والصحيه
وامنيه وكل ما تحتاجه المنطقه من خدمات
هذه المنطقه لم تكن مفيده من جهه ايواء
سته ملايين سوريه كانوا سيتوجهون الى
تركيا فحسب بل استقبلت نحو 500
الف سوري خلال السنوات السبع الاخيره
رجعوا اليها طواعيه وبطريقه مشرفه اود ان
اؤكد لكم ان الذهاب الطوعي للخمس مئه
وسبعين الف سوري الى المنطقه وبهذه
الطريقه المشرفه ما كان ليحدث لولا
الخدمات والانشطه والفرص التي اسستها
تركيا في المنطقه علما ان المنطقه هي جزء
من بلدهم ودولتهم وارضهم التي ولدوا
وكبروا فيها
سيد الوزير
لا احد ينكر ما قامت به تركيا بحق
اللاجئين بالتاكيد وانفسهم اللاجئين
السوريين لا ينكرون هذا لكن هو سؤال عن ان
هناك اشخاص يتم
ترحيلهم بالقوه يقولون ان لا زال اوراقهم
صحيحه لكن الشرطه تم ترحيلهم تعسفيا الى
شمال سوريا
هذا غير صحيح اقولها بصراحه كل مواطن سوري
يغادر الى الطرف الاخر من الحدود لدينا
ورقه موقعه منه تثبت مغادرته لتركيا
بارادته واؤكد ان كل ما يقال ليس حقيقه
مسلما بها
هنالك من يحاول استغلال وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وانواع اخرى من الاعلام لاثاره
الاراجيف والانطباعات السلبيه ونحن
نتابعهم
المغادره الطوعيه هي الاساس ولهذا وكما
قال رئيس الجمهوريه اكثر من مره فان
الجهات المتبرعه في تركيا وقطر تعمل على
مشروع في ادلب وغيرها يتضمن ثلاث نماذج من
المنازل التي سيتوجه اليها مليون مواطن
سوري وسيحتوي المشروع على مرافق اجتماعيه
وتجاريه وصناعيه تضمن استدامه الحياه وفي
الوقت الذي يرى فيه جميع اننا نسعى وبصبر
وايمان نابعين من ثقافتنا ومعتقداتنا فان
هنالك من يحاول ايصال صوره سلبيه عنا وهو
ما يؤسفنا جدا
لابد ان نذكر على قضيه
الاخطاء التي تحصل قصه الشاب بين
المغربيين التي انتشرت كثيرا في مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هؤلاء قيل في مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي انهم مغربيون اخذتهم
الشرطه بدون ان تتحقق منهم وارسلتهم الى
شمال سوريا
الاصلاحيه ان اقول لك الحقيقه كما هي في
بدايات العام 2023 حاول شاب مغربي التسلل
الى اليونان كما حاول شاب مغربي اخر
التسلل عبر الحدود الى بلغاريا اي بطريقه
غير قانونيه طبعا قوه امن البلدين اوقفت
الشابين وسلمتهما لقوات حفظ امن الحدود
التركيه وقوات الامن في محافظه ادرنه
شمالي تركيا قامت بالاجراءات الروتينيه من
تفتيشهما وتفتيش حقائبهما بحثا عن اي هويه
او جواز سفر دون فائده اي لم يتم العثور
على هويات وعند سؤالهما عن جنسيتهما قال
انهما سوريان وكما تعلم فان بيان الشخص
واعترافه هو الاساس المتبع في مثل هذه
القضايا السيده الوزير هم قالوا انهم
سوريون وليس اوراق رسميه
لم يحملها اي هويه تدل على جنسيتهما لقد
كان لاجئين غير نظاميين بكل ما تعنيه
الكلمه وقوات الامن الاوروبيه طردتهما
للطرف التركي ولم يكونا يحملان اي هويات
او جوازات سفر وعند الاستجواب تحدث مع
المسؤولين الاتراك باللغه العربيه الفصيحه
وقال انهما سوريان قوات الامن ابلغت دائره
الهجره والجوازات التي نقلتهما لمركز
ايواء المهاجرين غير النظاميين المؤقت في
ناحيه في محافظه اضنه حيث يتم ايواء
اللاجئين غير النظاميين على اعتبار انهما
سوريان بحسب زعمهما في مركز الايواء هذا
لا اعرف من استشار او من اشار عليهما ان
يبقي على اصرارهما على انهما سوريان
ويخفيا عن المسؤولين
جنسيتهم المغربيه لقد طلبت شخصيا اوراقهما
القانونيه واوراق عودتهم الطوعيه التي تم
ملئها بحضور المسؤولين الاتراك ورايت
بعينيه طلبهما الانتقال الاعزاز اي للطرف
السوري بعد انتقالهم للطرف السوري بقي
هناك خمسه اشهر لاحظ انهما لم يتواصلوا مع
القنصليه او السفاره المغربيه في تركيا
خلال الاشهر الخمسه واضح انهما كان يريدان
عبر الادعاء بانهما سوريان التسلل لتركيا
مره اخرى ومنها لاوروبا
سمعت بالقصه عبر الاعلام وذلك بعد تسلم
مهام وزاره الداخليه تواصلنا مع السفاره
المغربيه لدى تركيا وجلبنا اللاجئين من
اعزاز وتم ترحيلهما بيسر وسلاسه الى
المغرب بالتعاون مع البعثه الدبلوماسيه
المغربيه
كثيرا ما نستجوب لاجئين ونسالهم عن
اسمائهم فيقولون انهم لا يعرفون اسمائهم
ونسالهم ما جنسيتهم فيقولون انهم لا
يعرفون جنسيتهم ايضا عملنا صعب وطويل
ومليء بالصعاب
انا شاهدت
مقابلتك مع
السفير او القنصل المغربي
ومن اجل هذه القضيه لماذا لم يتم توضيح
هذا خصوصا من الجانب المغربي هذه اصبحت
قضيه راي عام وانتشرت كثيرا في مواقع
واساءت حقيقه الى تركيا
هذا يؤلمنا فنحن اخوه واصدقاء والاخوه
والاصدقاء يجب عليهم ان لا يتفوهوا
بعبارات تجرح بعضهم علينا ان نتخاطب بما
يتناسب واخوتنا لقد كان مغربيين الدعايا
انهما سوريان ونحن مضطرون لتصديقهما ولا
يعقل ان نعرف من هو المغربي ومن هو السوري
او غير ذلك لا توجد لدينا امكانيات لمعرفه
اللهجات او المنابع كما اني اجهل ماذا قال
هذان اللاجئان للمسؤولين المغاربه في
البعثه الدبلوماسيه المغربيه والحقيقه
المجرده هي ما اقوله بالضبط
في الجانب المقابل لا يمكن غض الطرف عن
تجاوزات حصلت من قبل اجهزه الامن واجهزه
وزاره الداخليه التركيه في بحق اللاجئين
وفي طريقه التعامل مع اللاجئين وحتى
السياح العرب هذه التجاوزات كيف يعني ما
هي رد فعل وزاره الداخليه للحد من هذه
التجاوزات بحق اللاجئين وخصوصا العرب منهم
شنو اقولها من كل قلبي السياح الاتون
لبلدنا هم ضيوفنا سواء كانوا عربا او من
دول اخرى نحن لا نتحدث عن اعداد كثيره نحن
نتحدث عن 50 مليون سائح نضعهم على الراس
والعين نحن نستضيفهم بما تقتضيه تقاليد
الضيافه التركيه الاصيله تركيا هي احدى
اكثر دول العالم امنا وهدوءا قوات الامن
التركيه منظومه تتكون من مجموعه من
المسؤولين المتمسكين بالقوانين وحقوق
الانسان الدوليه في حال تعدي مسؤول ما
مهما كان واخلاله بواجباته يتم استجوابه
ومحاسبته الجميع يعرف حساسيه تجاه هذا
الموضوع لسنين طويله اثناء خدمتي بصفه
قائمه مقام ومحافظا وعند تسلم منصب وزير
الداخليه اكدت اننا دوله قانون تراعي حقوق
الانسان الدوليه كما اكدنا مرارا وتكرارا
لقوات الامن والدرك وقوات خفر السواحل ان
عليهم مراعاه القوانين في تعاملهم
ومخاطبتهم مواطنين او الاجانب وبما يتناسب
مع عاداتنا وتقاليدنا واعرافنا وذلك ينسحب
على اللاجئين سواء كانوا نظاميين او غير
نظاميين لكن وجل من لا يسوع وفي حال ظهور
مسؤول ما لم يحسن التعامل مع واجباته رغم
القوانين والتعليمات فانه يحاسب اداريا
وعدليا
بموازاه هذا الموضوع موضوع اللاجئين هناك
موضوع اخر ايضا حساس جدا ويتصاعد الحديث
فيه اخيرا موضوع العنصريه والرئيس اردوغان
بالامس في حديثه في حفل تخرج ضباط
الجندرمه قال لا يمكن ان نسمح للعنصريه
والكراهيه وكراهيه الاجانب التي ليس لها
في تاريخنا وثقافاتنا ومعتقداتنا
بالانتشار في مجتمعنا لكن الواقع ان هناك
خطاب عنصري هناك ممارسات عنصريه
ولا يشاهد اي اجراءات للحد من هذه من هذا
الخطاب ومن هذه
من هذه التصرفات التي تحدث في الشارع
التركي
نعم لقد كنت حاضرا في خطاب السيد رئيس
الجمهوريه عند الاحتفال بتخريج ضباط الدرك
في هذا الحفل قال السيد رئيس الجمهوريه
انه لا يمكن ان نسمح للعنصريه وكراهيه
الاجانب التي ليس لها مكان في تاريخنا
وثقافتنا ومعتقداتنا بالانتشار في مجتمعنا
كما اضاف في خطابه ان الشعب التركي لن
يولي اهميه لمن ياتي بمثل خطاب الكراهيه
هذا سيقوم المدعون العامون والحقوقيون بما
يجب ان يقوم به في الوقت المناسب وفي اطار
القوانين لكن وكما ذكرت قبل قليل يوجد في
بلدنا مليون
و252 الف شخص مقيمون اقامه نظاميه وقدموا
الى تركيا من اجل استثمار ومنهم طلاب اتوا
من اجل تلقي العلم ومنهم من يعمل ويكد من
اجل مستقبل تركيا ورفاهيتها وهم اشخاص
ومؤسسات وشركات يعيشون بيننا وهم اخوتنا
وسنمضي في الطريق معا لكن ومن بين الخمسه
والثمانين مليونا ممن يشكلون الشعب التركي
العزيز هنالك فئه هامشيه ضئيله جدا لا تود
رؤيه اواصر المحبه بنا اشقاء والاخوه
وكونوا على ثقه ان الشعب التركي لا يابه
بهم نحن شعب يؤمن بان الخالق الاوحد ساوى
بين كل البشر ولهذا فان هؤلاء المتطرفين
المتفوهين بخطاب الكراهيه منبوذون بفضل
قيامنا الثقافي في
يعني
كلام سيد الوزير صحيح ان غالبيه الاتراك
لا يوجد ربما هذا الخطاب لكن الخطاب
العنصري واضح هناك رئيس حزب يتجول في
الشارع
يسال للناس عن بطاقات الهويه يدخل المحلات
ويتحقق ويوجه كلام عنصري خصوصا للعرب
والسوريين
ولم تتخذ بحقه اي اجراءات يعني على الاقل
في المنظور في الاعلام في لم نشاهد اي
اجراءات للحد من هذه التصرفات
تبدا
نحن دوله ذات نظام ديمقراطي وكما قلت في
بدايه حديثي سيد عبد العظيم فان كراهيه
الاجانب اصبحت مشكله عالميه والاحزاب
السياسيه في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي تزداد
عداوه للاجانب ومن ذلك ان الولايات
المتحده ايضا تشهد عداوه ضد هجرات
المكسيكيين ومعاملتهم
يوجد في داخلنا بعض الاشخاص الهامشيين من
اصحاب الافكار الهامشيه ممن يعلنون
عداوتهم للاجانب هذه مشكله هذه مشكله
ولهذا بامكاننا ان نحل هذا الموضوع عبر
الحوار وان نشرح ان هذا النوع من الافكار
ليس انسانيا او وجدانيا وان نركز مساعينا
لحل مشاكل واسباب الهجره في منابعها
من غير الممكن ان نجعل الجميع يفكرون
بالطريقه المثلى والجميله للاسف هنالك
هامشيون نحن نتابعهم ونراهم ونراقبهم
والاهم من ذلك ان المجتمع التركي لا
يوليهم اهميه او قيمه لكن هذا الخطاب له
مخاطر كثيره اليوم نشهد ايضا خطاب مضاد
هجمه على تركيا
واتهام كل تركيا بانه عنصريه بانها
يصلح للسياحه وللزياره
وهذا يؤثر على
منسوب السياحه على السائحين العرب خصوصا
سائحين الخليجيين يعني لم تتخذ اي اجراءات
لتصحيح ابتسم سيد عبد العظيم هذه الافكار
المسيئه لا يتفوه بها سوى مجموعه صغيره
للغايه لا قيمه لها عندما نتحدث عن
السياحه فان مؤسسات السياحه والفنادق
والتجار والعاملين في القطاع السياحي
يقدمون خدماتهم لخمسين مليون سائح ونهدف
لرفع العدد الى 70 مليون ثم الى 100 مليون
نحن من اكثر دول العالم امنا ودولتنا من
اكثر الدول المرغوب في سياحتها وكما قال
السيد رئيس الجمهوريه فانه من غير المعقول
ومن غير المنطقي ان نضحي بمئات السنين من
الاخوه والتعايش المشترك من اجل بعض
الاشخاص الذين يتفوهون بعبارات عنصريه
وبافكار هدامه
الكثير من مشاهدينا خصوصا الذين العرب
المتواجدين في تركيا سينتظرون الاجابه
منكم على هذا السؤال وهو قضيه
الاقامات
والجنسيه العقاريه كلها متوقفه منذ عده
اشهر وكثير منهم يواجه صعوبات هل ستعود
الامور الى طبيعتها هل الامور ممكن ان
تتحسن سيتم التعامل مع هذه الطلبات ام ان
الامور ستنتظر الى ما بعد الانتخابات
البلديه كما يشاع قبل ايام قليله فقط وقعت
على قرارات تتعلق بمنح الجنسيه للمستثمرين
الاجانب وبعثت بالاوراق لرئاسه الجمهوريه
وفيما يتعلق بمنح الجنسيات المستثمرين فان
الاجراءات مستمره كما كنا قد اعلنا عنها
مسبقا ودون تاخير لا توجد حاله تجنيس تم
ايقافها وهي مستوفيه لجميع الاوراق
شيء
نحن نرفع الاوراق والوثائق لرئاسه
الجمهوريه وبعدها يتم اتخاذ الاجراءات
المنصوص عليها قانونا والعمليه مستمره كما
يجب ان تكون واريد من اخوتها واصدقائي
العرب وكل الاصدقاء المستثمرين في العالم
ان يعرفوا ان اجراءات منح الجنسيه التركيه
للمستثمرين مستمره كما كانت ولا تاخذ وقتا
اطول من شهرين الى ثلاثه
سيد الوزير اشكرك جزيل الشكر على هذه
المشاركه معنا وعلى هذه
هذا النفس في الاجابه على اسئلتنا التي
تهم بالتاكيد
المشاهد العربي في الموضوعات الحساسه التي
ذكرت اشكرك جزيل الشكر على هذه المشاركه
كما اشكر لكم مشاهدينا الكرام حسن
المتابعه والى ان نلتقي في لقاء اخرى
استودعكم الله والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]